alright guys so what's up hello how is
it going nice to see you today we are
going this is a good wall to shoot on
this is like one of those famous
Instagram walls I think it looks good
anyway a super popular thing on YouTube
is product reviews like KC nice that is
one of my favorite content creators he
inspired me to make youtube videos and a
lot of his videos are just him reviewing
super neat products and I noticed that
BuzzFeed doesn't really do that until
now welcome to the first episode of
worth it like that that's already a show
on BuzzFeed so I have to come up with a
different name I got it to buy or not to
buy yet it like to this is my first ever
product review I've never done a product
review before because nobody sends me
products but I decided to take fate into
my own hands I emailed a bunch of
companies I told them I work for
BuzzFeed and if they send me their
products I might put them in my video so
let's go see what I got what's up man
what's up are you alright did I get my
[ __ ] back yes you got two packages
Wow I didn't get that many packages but
this one is really big so it's probably
gonna be something exciting let's go
check it out all right so I'm gonna
start with the bigger box first and you
get scissors
this week already wait all right and
boom all right now let's see what's
inside
[Music]
it's a black box inside of a brown box
the business hits more box that is just
more box inside I got a boosted board
I got it freaking you last mile vehicle
boosted board eyes got a bursted board
you stop freaking like this reg time oh
my breath I just got a booster board
what's the boost avoid I've never heard
of blister board ever in my life a
boosted board is an electric skateboard
and according to KCI stat and some other
youtubers it is by far the best electric
skateboard on the market so let's check
it out dude I am so excited I can't
believe they actually sent me a loser
board
okay I just saw the booster board inside
and it feels like I'm inside KC's video
thank you I'm so nervous
that's so nervous I don't know why I'm
so safe all right
[Music]
these wheels are freaking huge it
literally looks like the future it looks
so clean I well it should be cleaned
like they just sent it to me whoa okay
that's heavy
I'm gonna carry it and carry it like
that it's not that heavy actually this
is light
now if the skateboard was this light
that would be ha ha so there's no
instructions so I did the research and
this is the boosted plus it's basically
their newest classic boosted board it
goes 14 miles that's how long it can go
on on a fully charged battery it goes up
to 22 miles per hour
you've been 22 miles an hour on a
skateboard I've never been 22 miles per
hour on anything and it's 17 pounds si
heavy it's like a workout I could be
walking when I'm going to work and stuff
and I could be right curling it you know
all right enough talking let's go
outside and test it out should I open
the other box or go out before let me
see what's in the other box let me see
[Music]
like a Star Wars helmet and what is this
no there's a goggle for every day of the
week rock
this is the best helmet I've ever seen
in my life let's go outside and test it
out
[Music]
I felt comfortable on the board almost
immediately and it was really fun I'm a
quick learner though so I let my
co-workers test it
[Music]
it seemed easy for them to well for most
of them I can't do this thing this lose
the border in the world in conclusion
for most people it's not that hard to
learn how to boost it board and it's fun
but is it worth the price so this board
is $1,500 which is a lot of money but I
don't have to pay for any other mode of
transportation anymore I spent about two
hundred dollars a month on subways and
ubers so if I ride this board for about
seven months it's paid off an uber or a
subway usually take me 25 minutes to get
to work and if there's traffic or subway
issues I'm gonna be late this board gets
me to work in 50 minutes every single
time so to buy or not to buy I'm gonna
go with to buy it's so terrible
now the video doesn't end here if I want
to be like Casey I gotta ride like Casey
I don't
[Music]
I'm on
I felt ready to ride so I put on some
triple-a pads and went out
I got this whole boosted board thing
down so you know what I challenge you
Casey nice dad to a boosted board race
and if I win we become best friends okay
that's a little intense and if I win I
am the real Casey nice dad what what's
important now is we need to make sure
Casey nice dad sees this video so share
it tweet it IG it beep it Pia do
whatever you got to do so what do you
say Casey Quan race Casey probably isn't
gonna respond to this video so if you if
you just know how to skateboard DM me
and all all race we can we can have a
little race
[Music]
[Music]